so how can i use it well i'm going to go
with this 49 that I've established right
I see that I'm going to begin with a
power for do notice by the way remember
I said like this guy here that's that
new v turn at the front we didn't deal
with integration by parts in the context
of definite integrals before but it's
not that complicated to include
boundaries all that would mean is if you
are not just integrating UD me but if
you're integrating from a to be like so
once you've got here this UV part it's
already been integrated so it needs to
get boundaries does that make sense just
like if you integrate something else you
should get the boundaries minus a b RV
do you this just a slight extension of a
regular integration by parts form is
just that everything gets bad news
including this one it's been evaluated
at some points ok so that's going to
come into play here what's gonna be my
first line 1 over 4 right I identify my
party because this is this is I for from
not a pontoon ok and then what am I
getting in here so I'm going to
integrate sine X cos cubed right from
North planet ooh yeah plus welcome
at 33 lots of I to 4-2 yeah I supposed
to be speaking I should put the
boundaries here 22 ok I can move further
through this I can actually evaluate
this first thing what's happen you
evaluate our planet ooh what do you get
because it is cosine term here right
that's just going to become 0 when I
evaluated at 0 you still get 0 because
of the sign turn right how convenient
what happens over here I've got three
lots of what ok so I now return back so
this is I to now so instead of 1 over 4
i'll have a half yeah is that ok x times
1 ok I'm evaluating UV cause devil this
is I to write so it 2-1 yeah from North
to Virgin what trails off on the mt +
this is I to write so this is 2-1 3-1 of
i0 cause back yep so far so good so it's
a quarter this disappears I've got now
three Lots off I'm going to have a lot
of mr. Brackett in you I'm now ready to
integrate this to evaluate it but just
like it happened here this guy's going
to be 0 right i'm just going to 0 take
y0 sure what happens here well this is
two minus one which is one more oh I not
what I not this is the integral of cos
the power of 0 X which is just one right
sometimes the integral of 1 DX is just X
right
from Aisha written I forgot to write a
few from not to pilot ooh yes not as a
look yeah okay I'm ready now I can
actually evaluate or this thing no more
integration required because I've done
the last integral there so I've got a
quarter times three times a half which
is three on eight times what why don't
you happily this is PI on to take away 0
yep which looks to me like 3 PI on 60
okay so you can see what would I have
had to have done had I not establish the
recurrence relation right I would have
had to have done integration by parts
this time and then this time and then
how do we come okay but clearly because
just like in our original age of the X
sine X so I next example right you're
using the same kind of integration my
heart it's almost like you know you
prove one pair of play with similar and
you know I've got to be the other pairs
nothing to do but i'm using exactly the
same proof usual saying whatever so you
say similarly and similarly something
you have to rewrite it you're not sorry
go through the mechanics used to use
them over everything okay and that's the
strength of virtualization